I'm Grant Imahara.
I've been in the visual effects industry for about nine years now.
My specialty is electronics,...
...anything that lights up or moves.
Grant Imahara is somebody that I've worked with for years,...
...and I usually consult with him on anything...
...that's a little over my head regarding electronics.
He's able to almost instantaneously grasp a concept or technique...
...and apply it to what he's doing right away...
...and be able to get results with that.
Everybody is watching you all the time.
There are cameras all over him.
I remember what you said.
There is no dignity in television.
Once you accept that, it gets a lot more fun.
What we're about to do, we're gonna do for fun.
We've made a career out of making what seems impossible, possible.
I think that it brought about a renaissance of making science fun,...
...something that people could relate to...
...and say, "Oh, science isn't boring."
It's explosions and car crashes.
It's really a fun world to open up to.